okay I don't know how good my commentary
is gonna be for this but um I got a
place solid I have I've been learning
actually quite a bit against this this
beast this beast of a computer actually
it makes it definitely makes mistakes
the end game is without a doubt its
weakest point so this is what we call
this same ish set up against the Kings
Indian Queen d2 queenside castle Queen
d2 is not threatening Bishop h6 you can
be sure that the computer is not going
to miss any quick trick little tactics
so Queen d2 queenside castle or do I
take here and swap Queens if I take here
Knight here is threatening Knight c4 I
could play here I don't want to do I
want to keep the tension you gotta play
quick to against this monster monster
okay opposite sides castling and I think
there's much more success to have insta
computer when your opposite sides castle
so we're gonna see oh man I think now I
push in the center close it up I need
five star tonight c4 g4 night here g4
takes takes Knight a bunch of takes here
and then Knight they're not gonna be a
problem
I think I can maybe deal with it or even
like Knight here is maybe even let me
push first I think no 1995 to c4 is a
pain take care baby
I don't know what I want to do I got it
I have to move I'm definitely gonna be
making a ton of blunders against this I
make enough as is without commentating
we're trying to commentate g4 Knight
here I feel it could be played because
there's ensuing Forks take pod push
Knight a5 b3 is very weakening but maybe
it's okay
I'm gonna try that he's gonna go oh he
didn't go there that's that can't be
right can it okay we're gonna see g4
kick this night away first get out of my
house that's - get out of my house move
and now we're gonna attack that can't be
right
this thing's a monster though 20 seconds
it used I'm down to half my time
it's getting h5 could kill that night I
like my dark squared bishop better
though I feel like I should be winning
this I feel like that a lot against this
computer though I feel like that quite a
bit
h6 Bishop g5 Queen to h4 that's an
annoying pin isn't it
exchange off dark script bishops I want
to do my time my time my time just make
this how I get my rook involved on G
it's not gonna be a problem
tricky tactics over here
Bishop back Queen h2 stuff court Queen G
- oh boy better work Oh
125 let's try it
this better work I should have taken
that first I should have doubled here
first that's this isn't it's not gonna
work to try that this thing knows how to
defend it's a computer after all isn't
it wait a second I have something on my
sleeve don't i ah it's got to start sack
in the house ah I got it I think I have
it on the ropes it's all one other cool
feature if you didn't realize is it's
actually okay to trash-talk against a
computer haha I got you now are you
going I got you now what's up now what's
up now computer haha you gotta give up
your queen you're not so tough after all
are you oh no it's not so easy still
twenty-nine seconds you would think it's
easy but really it's not let's try this
take that rook take him he's free Oh
jack
23 oh man oh man I have to win this is
that working huh 17 seconds come on I
should be able to get this I have a
queen kill the night
yes he's sacking everything how do I
know it's a he get my knight involved
ten seconds pawn push and then me huh
right here clean here next I have it ah
seven seconds you're not going anywhere
may double checkmate
oh you should feel embarrassed oh man I
should just quit the chat right here
whoa